avec une petite équipe
formant l'association coconut hui nous
sommes ensemble d'amis au départ les
deux jeunes acteurs du territoire on
on a envie de mettre en lumière
bellefontaine et particulièrement le
potentiel entrepreneurial réveiller
c'est c'est l'entrepreneur qui sommeille
dans la commune et plus largement sur le
territoire et montrer qu'on a la
capacité de faire et du coup
quoi de mieux que de retrousser les
manches et de créer un événement samedi
à bellefontaine la tambouille soupe qui
se déroule de 19 heures à minuit sur la
plage donc pour nous c'est l'occasion de
le faire un focus un alliage entre la
gastronomie et l'animation culturelle et
la tradition dont il y aura la
possibilité comme son nom l'indiqué de
vivre un moment d'animation ancré dans
le tombeau dans la valorisation de la
musique et des artistes
nous avons aussi un dans le volet
artistique un défilé de mode qui est
proposé des artistes qui vont proposer
une petite prouesse que de poser des
tubes qu'on leur connaît sur le son du
tambour
donc ça c'est pour le volet animation et
puis je parlais d'un volet gastronomique
ben le nom le suggère on à la soupe en
tout ce sont pour l audio comme ça donc
nous avons la mairie qui nous suit nous
sommes aussi parce que l'on touche aux à
la valorisation d'une activité
touristique du coup on est soutenue
accompagnée par le cnt
sur cette opération bien entendu j'ai
parlé de la pêche et de l'agriculture
donc les pêcheurs et les agriculteurs se
mobilisent à nos côtés parce que c'est
là l'occasion aussi de faire ce coup de
projecteur fosse avant que nos les
produits qui seront proposés tout ce
sont que des produits locaux ça vient de
notre activité
du secteur en tout cas sur la zone nord
caraïbe et donc c'est l'occasion de
présenter une espèce de vitrine de tous
ces acteurs qui sont en synergie qui
tombent d'accord pour proposer quelque
chose d'intéressant à bellefontaine